now whilst it looked like warner
brothers were going to be releasing
two second clips of godzilla versus kong
over the next 45 years
this month everything's coming up mothra
as we not only have a new release date
but also a trailer time for things
hitting the web throughout this video
we're gonna be breaking it all down
but if this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy whose
favorite ice cream flavor
is rocky rodan now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so when you get to the level of
puns where you're using crap like rocky
rodan
then you know that things have been
dragged out for too long
godzilla versus kong has been pushed
back more times than john travolta's
hairline
however it's now been brought forward
like john travolta's wig
my god the monster movie will now be
making moves in march
and it was recently reported by deadline
that the two towering titans of terror
will be hitting our screens on friday
the 26th
there was a recently released brand new
teaser trailer by hbo max which showed
all kinds of footage from their upcoming
films like space jam and mortal kombat
amongst it there were two seconds of
godzilla vs kong
and we now have confirmation that the
movie will be sticking to their release
format of coming out on the streaming
service and in cinemas on the same day
i don't know what that means for the uk
as we're currently in the midst of our
400th lockdown
and whether theaters will be open by
then depends on boris
i'm not holding out breath though and
that's purely because the rollout of
track and trace went worse and the plan
to use the orca
and everything at the moment seems like
it's at a standstill
however if things are fine in dandy by
then it could mean that we may even get
a slightly earlier release like how he
did with wonder woman 1984.
that movie actually dropped 10 days
earlier in the uk but only about 15
cinemas were open in the country
so it was quite difficult to see it now
in america
joe biden is being inaugurated as we
speak and it also remains to be seen
what his lockdown policies are
so yeah there's gonna be lots of
different ways to see it but at least
it'll be exclusive on hbo max
and probably pirate bay in the uk but
i'm not condoning anything like that yet
before you start
now the movie will be competing with
zack snyder's justice league
which is judah released in the exact
same month due to it being the 26th then
i'm guessing that that movie will air at
the start of march
and we now have it confirmed that it
will be a four-hour film
rather than for one hour episodes i
don't know if warner brothers is that
confident in the project anymore if
they're moving godzilla vs kong to
pretty much compete with it
and though i don't want to do a full
breakdown on my thoughts of the four
hour announcement
i have been asked quite a lot so i'll
quickly give you them now
personally i think that the success of
the snyder cut relies
heavily on people being drawn into it
who aren't necessarily fans
sure this entire release is a love
letter to the hardcore supporters
but i think if you want that wider
success then you have to appeal to a
wider market
personally i think that the four-hour
run time will
be off-putting to a lot of people and
now i know that some will counter that
by saying
well we binge watch tv shows all the
time
but when it comes to a film i don't know
if people necessarily like to stop and
start it all the time
it's more of the negative connotation
that a four-hour film brings with it but
obviously
i will of course be watching it day one
and buying it on 4k
look yeah you could make it seven hours
and i'd still watch it
i'm just saying yeah my wife she doesn't
want to watch a four-hour film
i think it's going to be more
off-putting than welcoming and perhaps
warner brothers is moving up godzilla vs
kong to show that they are aware of this
too
i want something aimed more at the
casual market
now as for the teaser itself it was
actually posted on daniel rickman's
patreon that the official trailer will
be dropping on the 24th of january
the times for it on 9 a.m pacific time
midday eastern time
and 5 p.m in the uk haven't been able to
fully verify this but i've followed
daniel for a long time
and it's rare that he gets stuff wrong
the guy runs a really great patreon that
you should definitely check out
and i've left a link to it in the
description if you want to sign up and
see the news before anyone else
now the reason that i do think there is
some legitimacy to this is because i've
followed warner brothers for a while in
general
and they always tend to drop their
trailers at 5 p.m in the uk
now though this typically tends to be
either on a monday or thursday and the
24th is a sunday
the studio could want the data
themselves as
youtube at that point is pretty much
just a graveyard
mecha that what you want but why i do
think that it's imminent is because the
marketing for the movie has really
started to ramp up
not only was there that two second clip
mentioned earlier but we also got a
slight update to the synopsis
the new one reads in a time
when monsters walk the earth humanity's
fight for its future sets godzilla and
kong on a collision course
that will see the two most powerful
forces of nature on the planet
collide in a spectacular battle for the
ages
as monarch embarks on a perilous mission
into uncharted terrain
and to unearth the clues to the titans
origins a human conspiracy threatens to
wipe the creatures
both good and bad from the face of the
earth forever
is that you and conspiracy water
brothers eh you haven't
so it sounds like the two titans will be
smashing up some cities
like you should smash that thumbs up
button and if you want to support the
king of the spoilers
then click the subscribe button as soon
as that trailer drops
you know i'll be working on my breakdown
to get it out to you
so it's definitely worth sticking around
for and i love you very much
now in that two second footage it looked
like kong punched godzilla so hard
that his head came off so that the lads
heads come off
i've seen a lot of people going wild
over this but i just think that the vfx
artists probably didn't know how to
animate godzilla getting punched
and therefore just left it like that
sometimes stuff doesn't render properly
either
and in jurassic park there's actually a
frame when a velociraptor disappears for
a split second
so hey these things happen but you're
still fired
now on top of this the funko pops for
the two titans have just been revealed
and these 10 inches are bound to make my
wife wish she had more of a man in her
life
what now unlike most action figures they
don't really give away too much
and both characters look like they
haven't really started to fight yet
however if you look closely at kong's
chest we can see what looks like claw
marks
so it could be indicating one of the
injuries that he gets in the movie
either way i'll be buying these day one
and though we don't know whether we will
be getting a mechagodzilla one
i do think that it's highly likely a
figure for him was released at a toy
fair a while back
and to me that pretty much confirms that
the metal monster will be making his way
into the movie camach
all in all i can't wait to see this film
and guess who i'm rooting for
king kong yeah you heard it here first
i'm bloody rooting for kong
now get the hell off my video and and
hit the dislike button on the way out
your sucker
anyway that wraps up the the news and
obviously hello to your thoughts on it
and whether you're hyped for the movie
or not
comment below and let me know who you
want to win and if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up yeah
don't don't be a dick and hit that
dislike button now if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our full breakdown of the suicide
squad aircut
we go over the major differences and
things that were changed for the movie
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more
don't forget that on the 30th of january
we're giving away three copies of the
hobbit and lord of the rings 4k boxset
to our subscribers
and all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the news
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
and as a thank you you get videos like
this early we've also just started a new
instagram account in which you'll be
posting
lots of updates on forever and ever and
ever so definitely get following without
the way thank you for setting through
the video
i know i've been quite annoying on this
one and i apologize for that
but i've been paul you've been the best
and i'll see you next time take care
peace